Republican Party is not known for
championing environmental causes
president Trump believes climate change
is a hoax Trump administration has
announced plans to gut the Endangered
Species Act but today's open hostility
towards green policies wasn't always a
Republican way I think younger people
might be surprised to know that the
Republican Party has not historically
been opposed to environmental protection
or to conserving wild spaces and natural
resources in fact much of the framework
for environmental and conservationist
policies today was laid down by the GOP
take the United States Forest Service
for example it was set up by Republican
President Theodore Roosevelt in 1905 to
protect wildlife and public lands during
his presidency Roosevelt protected
approximately two hundred and thirty
million acres of public land and some of
the most vast and far-reaching
environmentally-friendly policies that
fundamentally changed America were
enacted by this guy yes that's right
Richard Nixon the president better known
for this one year of Watergate they
denied and this people have got to know
whether or not their presidents across
well I'm not a crook
Nixon achieved some of the biggest green
accomplishments of any modern American
president leaving an impressive record
when it came to implementing policies to
protect the environment he was from
California and his base was in Southern
California that had seen smog so he knew
that politics and he knew how bad smog
and pollution could get Nixon's
administration with the help of a
Democratic Congress passed many
environmental initiatives from
institutional reform to pollution
control he was an institution builder at
the federal level I mean one of the big
changes that happen in his tenure as
president was that environmental
regulation evolution and public health
and so on environmental health it was
moved up to the federal level because
the states weren't doing a good enough
job it was an extraordinary example of
cooperation between Republicans and
Democrats all those laws were passed on
a bipartisan basis people would be
surprised to know with
Welman support from both parties what's
most notable is it wasn't especially
controversial you know you've got
Republican members of Congress
supporting clean air clean water trying
to do something about toxic waste and
you have Republican presidents signing
the bills this is almost impossible to
think about nowadays environmentalism
had become a big concern for the
American people in the late 60s and
early 70s in all too many parts of
America it's becoming more and more
difficult to find breathable air
drinkable water they had witnessed a
devastating oil leak in santa barbara
california and rampant pollution in
other parts of the country New Yorkers
learned about it at first hand when
freak weather conditions in July trapped
poisonous fumes just above the city
environment was kind of a unifying issue
it was an issue to where Republicans
such as him they they also thought that
you know we needed clean water that
pollution was a really big concern in
1968 Nixon created the task force on
Environment and Congress was also doing
its part it approved one of the first
laws to establish a national framework
for environmental protection the
National Environmental Policy Act of
1969 the purpose of the Act was and is
to this day to make sure the government
conducts assessments before it begins
any federal projects that significantly
affect the environment that includes
construction of airports buildings and
military complexes but in 1970 Nixon
proposed something that would change the
way the government dealt with the
environment he submitted to Congress a
plan to set up the Environmental
Protection Agency the EPA strengthening
our attack on environmental problems
both Nixon and Congress were on a roll
they passed the Clean Air Act in 1970 in
order to tackle air pollution and set
standards for what type of air
pollutants can be released in 1972 Nixon
signed the Clean Water Act to regulate
water quality the Act also made it
illegal to discharge pollutants into
navigable waters without a permit and it
wasn't just environmental legislation
that Nixon was signing
1973 he approved the Endangered Species
Act the Act granted the government
powers to protect species at risk of
extinction of course whether Nixon was
genuinely passionate about saving the
environment is up for debate it was kind
of pushed into it a little bit he might
not have done it had he not had a
Democratic Congress and as well as
environmental informed advisors to steer
him that direction but whether it was a
political calculation or personal
passion for the environment that drove
Nixon's green policies the fact remains
that a Republican president supported
laws that have significantly changed the
lives of Americans clean air and clean
water the wise use of our land the
protection of wildlife and natural
beauty parks for all to enjoy these are
part of the birthright of every American
so what happened it's really the more
recent Republican administrations and
the more recent Republican members of
Congress I'd say in the last twenty to
thirty years is that a really world back
Environmental Protection and during this
period the more recent period
Environmental Protection and especially
climate change have become deeply
partisan issues and then in 1981 a new
president takes office guided by a
free-market ideology innately hostile to
government regulation what happens is
Reagan comes in along with him are
opponents of environmental protection
through regulation what President Reagan
did which really set back environmental
protections he appointed a Secretary of
the Interior and an administrator of the
EPA who were essentially opposed to the
missions of those agencies Reagan
appointed and Gorsuch who keep in mind
didn't like the EPA to lead the EPA and
for two years they do what they can to
curb it to dismantle Avani and Gorsuch
took apart the whole enforcement
division at the EPA they proposed
massive cuts in EPA and other
environmental agencies
wanted to open up all these federal
lands to the oil drillers and the
grazers and so forth the environmental
programs managed to survive some blows
by the Reagan administration in large
part due to the pushback from Congress
the Senate belonged to the Republicans
but the house was a blue majority both
Watt and Gorsuch eventually left
Reagan's next appointments were more
friendly to the environmental agencies
the preservation of our environment is
not a partisan challenge it's common
sense what happens during the Reagan
administration is the embrace of anti
statism and a strong dislike for big
government and from there the Republican
Party starts going through a bit of a
metamorphosis I wouldn't say it's been a
kind of a linear road where Republicans
suddenly decided you know on mass they
didn't care about the environment I
think that what's happened over time is
a combination of things
but one is this sort of embrace of
deregulation generally in the Republican
Party I would say environmental
protection was part of the deregulatory
moment in the Reagan administration and
it's part of an anti federal government
era which Reagan of course assured in
when he said the government is not the
solution to our problem government is
the problem
conservative think tanks and
corporations also started getting
involved since the 1990s more than
two-thirds of contributions from the oil
and gas industry have gone to Republican
candidates and party committees
another thing that changed the other is
a kind of loss of moderate Republicans
in the House and in the Senate and the
loss of that species of Republican means
that you have much more extreme
Republicans and there's kind of a
similar dynamic happening over time in
the democratic party where you see a
divergence between your average
Republican and your average Democrat
which makes bipartisan law very hard to
pass it may come as a surprise to know
that one Republican president that was
surprisingly moderate and bipartisan
when it came to the environment was
George HW Bush if we believe that every
American expects and deserves clean air
and then we act on that belief HW Bush
actually should be known and given
credit for being quite environmental
president he signed the most important
revision of the Clean Air Act since it
was originally passed in 1970 and it
included a system for dealing with the
problem of acid rain which was
destroying lakes and forests the
first-ever market trading scheme for you
know issuing allowances to pollute but
creating a scheme to buy and sell those
allowances is a kind of market mechanism
for controlling air pollution and then
in the George W Bush era we saw really a
period of again retrenchment he pulled
out of the Kyoto Protocol which was the
international agreement on climate
change at the time but what really
intensifies the partisan battle is
climate change
it sort of creeps into consciousness as
an issue and it only becomes a really
compelling issue that the public becomes
familiar with in the late 90s and early
2000s
clearly to me this climate change issue
is one of the principal challenges that
we face the challenge that should we
fail to meet it could imperil the lives
of our children and if not our children
our grandchildren by that point it
becomes clear that this is going to be a
very partisan issue because climate
change is about the energy system you
know it's about oil and gas and how we
fuel our electricity and how we feel our
transportation and suddenly becomes
clear that this is going to be something
the parties divide
Jody Freeman was also a counselor for
energy and climate change during the
Obama presidency in 2009 after taking
office Obama attempted to get a
comprehensive climate and energy bill
passed but what Freeman and Obama found
was that it's not just about convincing
the other party about the importance of
implementing extensive climate change
policies
it's about convincing your own to even
though it was a Democratic Congress for
the first two years in the Obama
administration that new legislation
could not get through and that's because
energy and climate change are not
clearly just Republican and Democratic
issues that people don't vote just based
on party they vote based on where their
state is positioned in terms of what
kind of resources they have are they a
coal state are they a wind state are
they a state that's rich in renewables
or a state that has oil and gas so it's
very hard to get support even when you
your party controls the Congress once
the midterm election happened the
Democrats lost control of the Congress
and so there was no way
climate change legislation was going to
get done the Trump administration has
made a targeted effort to rollback
Obama's legislations and efforts to
combat climate change the impact of
these rollbacks could have detrimental
consequences the Republican Party went
from this there is no disagreement with
regard to the need for all nations to
cooperate share their knowledge and
their brains and cleaning up the
environment of the world to this as
someone who cares deeply about the
environment which I do I cannot in good
conscience support a deal that punishes
the United States which is what it does
we've lost our leadership role in the
international community on these issues
and the international community is
really startled and disappointed that
the US has disappeared on many other
diplomatic issues there's no question
that this is a moment of complete
retrenchment on climate change with the
energy policy
[Music]